i talk to each of these stars describe
the color of a set and discuss with them
the color they're going to wear the
silhouette so we try to get a
differentiation of costume and all of
the actresses you must remember that
this is the one time that an actress
presents herself as her own image not a
character in the film now the academy
does not tell a star what she can or
cannot wear
but since this is the most important
time of the year in hollywood since the
academy wars goes all over the entire
world and it represents not only our
industry but the entire country we feel
sure that the stars aren't going to wear
any of the you know freaky far out
unusual fashions and we feel that this
year it's going to be the most beautiful
fashion show there's ever been
this year there are four period films
one modern this is a sketch richard
burton and of a thousand days 16th
century
then we have hello dolly which is 1895
daily daily which is 1910 they shoot
horses don't they the depression 1930
and then one ultra-modern film sweet
charity
well i don't have crises because you see
i have a crash crew backstage that are
women equipped with needles pins liquid
cement scotch tape all sorts of things
you know one time we had a star who was
just ready to go on stage stepped on her
dress whole skirt almost came up and she
says i can't go on so we pinned her
together and on she went we've had so
many strange fashions the last few years
we've had the micro the mini the midi
we've had see-through clothes we've even
had unisex
nobody not even the designers knows
exactly what's going to happen but i
know one thing that on april the 7th
you are going to see at the academy
awards i think the world's greatest
fashion show because you're going to
have factions from every great designer
all over the world modeled
by the most beautiful women in the world
the hollywood stars